[Música]
ya son al menos 18 de las 34 capitales
de provincias capturadas por el grupo
talibán en afganistán los insurgentes
tomaron unas últimas horas el control de
kandahar las carga y feroz ccoo mientras
tanto ya son más de 250.000 los
desplazados tropas estadounidenses y
británicas llegan al país asiático para
evacuar a su personal
desde hoy el periódico la prensa de
nicaragua no circula más en su versión
impresa los insumos para hacerlo siguen
bloqueados por el gobierno de daniel
ortega la sociedad interamericana de
prensa calificó de hostil y anti
libertad de prensa lo sucedido por el
diario más antiguo del país tenemos
análisis en esta emisión
el líder de samsung lee jones acusado
por corrupción saludo este viernes desde
la cárcel en libertad condicional debido
a un polémico indulto concedido por el
gobierno de corea del sur y ayón que
cumplía cinco años de prisión por
malversar fondos ocultar activos en el
extranjero entre otros
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 sirve a blanco
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos con el rápido y contundente
avance de los talibanes en afganistán
hoy capturaron otras tres capitales de
provincia y rodean gradualmente a kabul
la capital de ese país la ofensiva se
produce pocas semanas antes de que
estados unidos termine oficialmente la
guerra de dos décadas con el retiro de
sus tropas es la primera vez en casi 20
años de guerra que el gobierno de kabul
pierde tantos territorios en cuestión de
días veamos ahora en este mapa cuáles
son las ciudades bajo el control talibán
como vemos kandahar las carga y feroz
ccoo fueron las últimas ciudades tomadas
por los insurgentes kandahar ha sido
considerada como la capital histórica
del país ya que en el pasado sirvió
durante siglos como centro del poder en
afganistán y es que según acnur el
avance talibán ha dejado al menos unos
250 mil desplazados desde el mes de mayo
y un 80 por ciento de ellos son mujeres
y niños preocupados por la seguridad de
sus connacionales eeuu y reino unido
anunciaron el envío de tropas para
garantizar el retiro seguro de su
personal
al respecto previamente hablamos con
nuestro corresponsal en washington dice
que hizo al basque sobre los anteriores
intentos de obama tram de retirar las
tropas de afganistán y esto fue lo que
nos dijo prácticamente desde georgetown
libros que empezó esta guerra todos los
presidentes han querido retirar las
tropas de hecho llama mucho la atención
un comentario del ex presidente de
donald trump que dijo que está retirada
de tropas sería muy diferente o su
gobierno si él fuese todavía presidente
dijo que se haría bajo con visiones
diferentes y que sería muy exitosa y muy
buena la retirada de sus tropas sin
embargo pues bailén el show les ha
reiterado ya en varias ocasiones que
está convencido y no se arrepiente de su
decisión de retirar las tropas decisión
que ni siquiera obama pudo cumplir a
pesar de que fue una promesa de campaña
en cuanto a las tropas y en cuanto a
cómo están preparados los arcanos pues
son cerca de 300.000 hombres afganos
entrenados por los estadounidenses que
están en la que están tratando de hacer
contrapeso a los talibanes que son
75.000 hombres así que muchos analistas
dicen que están suficientemente
preparados lo que pasa es que hay mucha
división en afganistán y eso está
afectando entonces pues la avanzada de
forma positiva para los talibanes en
afganistán
cambiamos ahora información la prensa el
principal diario de nicaragua y el más
antiguo del país no tendrá desde hoy su
circulación impresa porque se quedó sin
insumos el gobierno daniel ortega tiene
retenido el papel para poderlo imprimir
la sociedad interamericana de prensa al
respecto calificó este hecho de hostil y
ante libertad de prensa y alertó que el
gobierno no ha respondido a varias
cartas y mensajes enviados por los
directivos de este medio de comunicación
para analizar lo que allí estaba
ocurriendo nos acompaña a alberto cortez
ramos él es catedrático politólogo de la
universidad de costa rica editor del
libro anhelos de un nuevo horizonte de
aportes para una nicaragua democrática
gracias señor cortés por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 cuál es el
panorama de los medios de comunicación
en nicaragua tras esta escalada de
represión en el país y no es la primera
vez que sucede esto con un medio de
comunicación y cada vez son más los
periodistas que salen y lamentablemente
de nicaragua
definitivamente este es un hecho más que
evidencia a la deriva autoritaria que
tiene este gobierno efectivamente
la pareja presidencial viene conculcando
una serie de derechos políticos básicos
fundamentales para la convivencia
democrática ha encarcelado periodistas
también tiene una legislación que
básicamente es
represiva y persecutoria de el
periodismo y de los periodistas y este
es digamos un
aporte más en la línea de conculcar la
libertad de expresión en nicaragua y eso
abona a un clima político autoritario y
represivo que impide la realización de
una salida democrática político
democrática en las elecciones que vienen
recuerdo que están a pocos meses de
hacer las elecciones en noviembre si
alberto hablemos precisamente de esas
elecciones presidenciales ya que usted
tocó el tema en la cárcel están 32
líderes opositores entre ellos 7
precandidatos presidenciales tendrá
entonces ortega unos comicios sin
competencia que hay 130 y estos 32 son
recientes no hay posibilidad de elección
con competencia
las personas que están entre las
personas que están detenidas están las
que tienen mayor posibilidad de
representar a una oposición
alternativa
frente a la oposición
colaboracionista que es lo que está
quedando en el juego electoral entonces
no hay posibilidad de que hay un proceso
electoral con condiciones mínimas y
competir y ahora las decisiones de los
precandidatos opositores a la
presidencia de nicaragua además de todos
aquellos que critican al gobierno ha
generado un choque diplomático con los
países que han levantado la voz ante
esta situación política de nicaragua le
importa esto a daniel ortega a menos de
tres meses de estas elecciones
presidenciales
pareciera que no le importa pero lo
cierto es que ahí se plantea la
hipótesis de que estas
primero que estas acciones diplomáticas
equivocadas que están tomando contribuye
a su aislamiento y aunará a su no
reconocimiento después de 7 de noviembre
el reconocimiento de las elecciones y lo
que se supone es que la pareja
presidencial la pareja dictatorial
quiere básicamente utilizar todas estas
medidas como elementos para negociar un
reconocimiento alguna forma de
legitimación después del 7 de noviembre
o sea para la pareja dictatorial el
juego empieza después del 7 de noviembre
y lo que se buscaría negociar liberación
de personas detenidas el levantamiento
de algunas de las restricciones
alivian a miento de medidas represivas a
cambio de suspensión de sanciones y
también algún tipo de reconocimiento que
les permita una cierta normalidad entre
comillas
alberto gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
como periodista siento mucho lo que pasa
con respecto a la libertad de prensa en
nicaragua
continuamos con más información cuba
registra un promedio de 8.000 casos
diarios de kobe 19 la isla se enfrenta a
un brote de coronavirus por la variante
delta que ha agotado a su sistema de
salud para enfrentar el virus cientos de
doctores regresaron a la isla cubanos de
la diáspora envían medicamentos para
aplacar la escasez y el presidente díaz
canel llamó al compromiso para superar
este pico de la pandemia carolina los
alleo nos amplia
cuba sufre un pico pandémico por la
variante delta con un incremento de
miles de casos diarios desde semanas a
pesar de contar con un plan de
vacunación que ya inmunizó a más del 60%
de la población y dos vacunas producidas
localmente soberana y abdalá el sistema
de salud cubano se encuentra sobrepasado
tenemos bastante fallecido una
institución y que tenemos una sola
morgue que tenemos un solo crematorio y
que son muchos fallecidos el presidente
de cuba miguel díaz-canel mencionó los
esfuerzos que se realizan para enfrentar
la pandemia y pidió hacer un esfuerzo a
la población les pido comprensión
compromiso y pensamiento sobre todo para
en el menor tiempo posible estar en las
condiciones para sobrepasar este pico
pandémico que podemos vencer señal de la
agudeza de la situación cientos de
doctores cubanos que se encontraban en
misiones en diferentes países regresaron
a la isla para brindar apoyo en
hospitales si bien cuba mantuvo los
casos de kobe bajo control durante el
primer año de la pandemia la variante
delta cambió esta situación
los casos que surgen a partir de la de
la cepa delta que es una cepa más
expansiva de una cepa más
agresiva indiscutiblemente que nos está
creando situaciones complejas a nivel de
a nivel hospitalario
también desde el extranjero llegan
medicamentos para aliviar la escasez de
productos de salud muestra de la
solidaridad de la diáspora cubana el
gobierno cubano que enfrente el pico
pandémico con un embargo de eeuu y en
temporada de huracanes llamó al personal
de salud a acelerar los procesos de
vacunación suministros de oxígeno y
medicamentos
dejamos a un lado de la pandemia pero
seguimos en américa latina' hoy se
conmemora en mexico la caída del imperio
mexica conocido como civilización azteca
el 13 de agosto de 1521 los
colonizadores españoles se tomaron la
capital tenochtitlán ante manos de los
grupos indígenas enfrentados con el
poder azteca en lo que históricamente se
describe como una conquista sangrienta y
también brutal el aniversario ha dado
lugar a distintas reivindicaciones de la
cultura originaria de los pueblos
mexicanos ya la investigación sobre los
principales episodios de la colonización
española veamos el siguiente informe
se cumplen 500 años de la caída del
imperio azteca tras 75 días de sitio el
13 de agosto de 1521 los españoles
guiados por hernán cortez tomaron
brutalmente la capital del imperio
méxico-tenochtitlan la conquista fue
posible por la alianza de los colonos
hispánicos con pueblos indígenas
confrontados a los aztecas los días
previos al aniversario en ciudad de
méxico grupos de defensa de la cultura
prehispánica conmemoraron la resistencia
de sus raíces a través de siglos de
presiones pues me siento orgullosa
porque estamos a 500 años recordando no
la caída estamos recordando el
resurgimiento de nuestras raíces que son
muy profundas raíces que penetran el
zócalo la plaza principal de ciudad de
méxico que fue levantada sobre el centro
político y religioso de tenochtitlan
nuestra cultura la escribieron los
vencedores entonces esos vencedores
dejaron escrito mediante su pensamiento
su palabra porque está en español
su idea entonces está todo alterado
tergiversado distorsionado con el
objetivo de repensar la historia un
grupo de investigadores de la unam
desarrolló el videojuego y aúpan sobre
la historia de los tlaxcaltecas uno de
los pueblos mesoamericanos que participó
junto a los españoles en el derribo del
imperio azteca hay diferentes versiones
sobre esta historia esta es una más la
de los tlaxcaltecas la del pueblo atrás
caltech a que se erigió como vencedor de
los de las guerras y las alianzas de
conquista y así lo expresaba en
documentos como el lienzo de tlaxcala
500 años después documentos como el
lienzo de tlaxcala son un túnel del
tiempo a la colonización española
cambiamos ahora información y también de
continente vamos a europa donde la
policía británica identificó al
responsable del tiroteo en la ciudad de
plymouth se trata de jake dating son de
22 años de edad quien con una escopeta
mató a cinco personas incluida una niña
y luego de los hechos se quitó la vida
con la misma arma la policía aún trabaja
en identificar los motivos de este
crimen y no queda claro si davidson
sufría de algún tipo de problemas de
salud mental
y vamos ahora hasta a corea del sur
donde el líder de samsung lee jae yong
salió en libertad condicional de la
prisión donde se encontraba recluido por
corrupción esto debido a un polémico
indulto concedido por el gobierno que ha
dividido a la sociedad surcoreana los
detalles con nuestro corresponsal en
seúl andrés sánchez
el líder de samsung y jason ha salido de
prisión donde se encontraba recluido por
corrupción tras recibir un indulto del
gobierno que ha vivido profundamente a
la sociedad surcoreana a su salida de
prisión y se ha disculpado ante los
medios por haber generado inquietud al
pueblo surcoreano y ahí mismo en la
salida de la cárcel se han congregado
también personas tanto a favor como en
contra de su puesta en libertad aquellos
en contra consideran que la decisión de
indultarlo contraviene la promesa del
actual gobierno del presidente mundial
de luchar contra la corrupción
-aquellos a favor de su indulto en
cambio subraya en el peso que tiene su
figura la del líder de una empresa que
genera la quinta parte de la riqueza
nacional de hecho el propio gobierno
surcoreano ha hablado de interés
nacional al argumentar a favor del
indulto que le correspondía ahí puesto
que ya había cumplido el 60 por ciento
de la pena de dos años y medio de cárcel
a la que fue sentenciado el tribunal que
lo juzgó lo encontró culpable de haber
pagado durante años sobornos a la red de
extorsión creada por la ex presidenta
surcoreana para kun y su socia jason
seels conocida como la rasputín ah y
actualizamos nuestra página web france24
puntocom para que siempre esté conectado
con nosotros estamos triturando la
delicada situación social y política que
ocurre en afganistán con el avance de
los talibanes luego de tomar kandahar y
herat ya se toman más ciudades al sur de
esa nación asiática también el anuncio
de eeuu de mandar tres mil soldados para
poder evacuar con seguridad a todo su
personal
hasta aquí el informativo continua con
nosotros muy buen día para todos
[Música]